oh boy yeah I suspect more than a few
enemy fans are gonna be gunning for me
after this one so I recently wrapped up
what had been the primary feature on the
somewhat sporadically updated council of
geeks podcast feed for the last several
months it was called the SIA space
cowboy podcast the premise of that show
was that for the first time in just
about 15 years I went back and rewatched
all the episodes of Cowboy Bebop
including the movie and gave my thoughts
one entry at a time I thought it would
be nice to sort of just cap off the
whole thing here in video format with
you folks you know do a bit of an
overview covering my feelings on the
show as a whole it's bit more relevant
now that Netflix is actually moving
forward with its live-action remake I
was gonna do this video anyways but you
know that whole announcement it made it
more topical so I'm not exactly
complaining about the timing so uh yeah
Cowboy Bebop
now when I watch this anime for the
first time all the way through way back
around 2003 ish my overall thoughts
coming out of it at least as best as I
recall them were it was pretty good I'm
not sure why anyone everyone is you know
falling over each other to be the first
in line to worship at the altar of this
particular thing so coming back to it a
decade and a half later I was more than
a little curious to see if time distance
and just my own you know natural
maturation as a human being would give
me a different overall feeling he really
didn't I still think is pretty good but
also severely over praised in many
circles so rather than change my
perspective on the show the entire
exercise
of revisiting it instead gave me the
opportunity to better understand why I
felt that way in the first place
Senate changing my mind I can now simply
articulate what I've always felt about
the show better than I could when I was
working off of faded memories which was
kind of all I had before I did the
rewatch now I do really want to
emphasize this Cowboy Bebop is by no
means a bad show it is actually quite
good which is why I use words like over
praised or overrated because I mean them
very literally if people recommend a
restaurant to you and they tell you that
the steak there is the best steak you've
ever eaten you then go there have the
steak and even if that steak is amazing
and worthy of praise if it isn't the
single best steak you've ever eaten then
it's still fair to call it overrated
also I fully acknowledge that at least
some of my sticking points can probably
be countered with a cultural argument
that I'm complaining about things which
are established or expected tropes
within Japanese entertainment culture
and the history of anime in general and
I just don't get it because I'm not from
there and from that culture and you know
what I'll even cop to that being fair
but I'll point out that I can only bring
the perspective that I actually have and
there's only so much I can do to account
for cultural factors when it comes to
you know some of these things besides I
would point out that the fans who over
praised this thing to me in the first
place also weren't from the Japanese
culture and I still see Cowboy Bebop
labeled as a show that works even for
folks not normally into anime so I kind
of feel like that's a wash ultimately so
that's more than enough preamble let's
jam
for those who don't already know Cowboy
Bebop
is a science fiction anime series it
aired in Japan in 1998 and 1999 it had a
film release in 2001 as well as a manga
version it was a solid hit in Japan but
became probably the first big anime hit
of the new millennium in America that
happened when it was aired on the
Cartoon Network in 2001 as part of the
launch lineup for the brand-new Adult
Swim late-night airing block I don't
think anybody could have really
predicted how big a deal Adult Swim
would actually end up being but
predictable or not there's little
question that the show's placement there
helped propel the interest in it over
here in the States there had been anime
series ported over to the u.s. before
that I mean of course a ton of them in
fact they even really big hits Sailor
Moon Pokemon transformers many many many
others but the thing is those are pretty
much all aimed at kids or at the very
least we'll rieta 'td to meet the
standards of what were considered kids
shows in the u.s. at the time Cowboy
Bebop was really the first adult aimed
series to get a serious push in the u.s.
it's kind of surprising it took that
long actually especially given that
adult targeted anime films were already
a pretty decent niche market with you
know the likes of Ninja Scroll vampire
hunter D goes to the shell and of course
Akira
they all had made waves to varying
degrees well ahead of Cowboy Bebop but
then again the list of networks willing
to air stuff like Cowboy Bebop without
heavy edits it was pretty short I mean
when it came to the films that I
mentioned yeah a video store remember
those huh but they could section off
animated films that were not meant for
kids it's harder for a network to do
that and it was something that wasn't
really done before Adult Swim that was
basically the entire point of that block
now at the time a premium cable channel
could have aired it without much worry
but thinking back is hard to match
HBO or Showtime stepping up to give this
a shot at that point in time even the
boundary pushers like Fox for example
which had had the Simpsons and it had
already launched Family Guy by that
point even they were really only going
adult with comedies and while Cowboy
Bebop can be funny very at times the
stuff that would make it too harsh for
most networks they're not jokes so don't
swim ended up being really the perfect
vehicle at a time when the show was
still relatively current so the series
follows a group of interplanetary bounty
hunters sometimes called cowboys who
make their home on a spaceship called
the bebop when the series starts it's
just spike Spiegel and jet black on the
ship but it isn't long before they pick
up the duplicitous Faye Valentine the
rambunctious Edie and the smartest
member of the entire group a Corgi
called ein money is usually pretty tight
they try to scrape by by tracking out
bounties even as most of the crew are
sometimes haunted by figures or actions
from their own past the details of which
get drip fed across the run of the show
the setting hops from planet to planet
sometimes even takes place primarily in
space or on the ship and I should note
since it is set in space there's no
aliens so we're dealing with humans
despite the space setting it's a little
bit like Joss Whedon's Firefly in that
way actually the tone of any given
episode can vary wildly depending on the
nature of the bounty that they're
tracking what aspects of whose past is
being touched on and what supporting
characters get picked up along the way
some of the episodes are funny some are
melancholy some are action-heavy some
are about the fields there's even one
that I find genuinely disturbing there
isn't much in the way of recurring
characters outside of the main group
there's a recurring comic relief trio of
old man
get like one joke scenes every couple of
episodes that's kind of it though
aside from them the few characters who
pop up more than once mostly tying into
spikes background and history the show
taken as a whole you might even be able
to describe it as picaresque which is a
storytelling technique that's more about
small glimpses of a world and of
characters through almost kind of
vignettes rather than telling a cohesive
overall story arc it doesn't quite do
the Buffy or the modern Doctor Who thing
where there's a through line that's
always working in the background yet at
the same time it's not safe to say that
every episode is completely
self-contained either there are a couple
of two-parters as the series goes along
and through digging into spikes history
and usually giving him the most screen
time the show seems to primarily
position spike as the lead character
which is a bit frustrating for me
personally as I actually find him to be
the least interesting member of the crew
so let's now talk about
my opinion on Spike is probably the
first major divergence between my
feelings about the show and what others
tend to express about it or at least
what I've seen I just find spike kind of
boring and also I get really frustrated
when I see fans on ironically label him
as cool oh he's he's trying to be cool I
will grant you that and if you
cherry-pick certain episodes he even
pulls it off but he's honestly a bit of
a doofus he's got a pretty fragile ego
doesn't really have a solution for
anything besides hit it hit it again and
if that doesn't work maybe try shooting
it combining this with the deliberate
attempts at cool doesn't feel like it's
adding depth I mean not for me at least
it makes me just unable to take him
seriously during the times when the show
very clearly wants me to be taking him
seriously for being positioned as the
lead character yes oh he doesn't have a
character arc he doesn't change or grow
we only get flashbacks to a time when he
was marginally different from how he is
now so if he ever had a character arc or
significant growth it happened before
the show even started I also find his
age to be at odds with the background
that he's given I don't want to dwell
too long at this point because honestly
I've seen it in enough other animes that
this is one of those things that I'm
prepared to chalk up to just being a
cultural thing but it still really does
bug me so here we go most of the
characters aren't old enough for their
characterization to ring true to me now
to take spike he used to be involved in
a criminal syndicate worked his way high
enough into the ranks that it mattered
to the guys at the top when he left he's
now been with Jett long enough to have a
pretty set rapport when the show
actually starts so they obviously didn't
just connect he's also apparently a
martial arts master and he's 27 years
old
Faye's age is actually kind of a wonky
thing but she's it
tiddly 23 years old and while some of
what we learned about her background
certainly justifies her jaded Ness her
skill set seems way out of whack with
how long she could have possibly been
pursuing and mastering things like
sleight of hand gunplay piloting etc
Edie gets a pass because it's openly
acknowledged that she's a computer
prodigy and we also don't get enough
specifics about of a pass or anything
else so for it to actually feel off or
go no wait that doesn't add up we don't
have the pieces to add up in the first
place
and as for Jett he's a former cop and as
you'd expect he's a bit jaded from his
time in that line of work he's got kind
of a Zen thing going on or at least
tries to I mean he's very much the dad
of the group and he's just he just kind
of has the already seen everything vibe
to him he's 36 he's younger than I am no
I don't buy it
both spike and Jack need at least a
decade add to their ages for me to buy
either one of these Baxter's for the
personas which I'll give that to the
Netflix they have cast actors who are
ages that I'll actually buy this but you
know again as I said I get a sense that
in many animes character histories they
get they get this whole thing worried
their background can't possibly fit
their age and nobody is allowed to be
over 40 except in such cases where they
look like they're pushing a hundred so
I'll just move on from this but it just
bugs me I I had to get it off my chest
Wow okay yeah I'm dipping into
grievances a bit sooner than I'd planned
okay focus you can do this all right so
ignoring the age issues the other
characters work better for me than spike
does Edie is probably my favorite though
she is the very definition of a
supporting character even the episodes
where she's at the center of things like
say mushroom samba they don't really
dive much into any kind of depth or
exploration of her or anything like that
she's very much what you see is what you
get kind of character and what you get
is just kind of weird I always like dad
I like her even more now after the
rewatch because I'm a parent I can
recognize some of my daughter's goofier
moments in this character's behaviors
that endears heard to me a little bit
more I mean Ed's a teenager with the
skillset of a 30-something and the
carefree attitude of a six-year-old
she's great though admittedly the
shallowest character of the law but I
mean when you're that carefree
who needs layers they took me a little
while to warm to largely because I just
had a hard time buying that the others
even let her stick around after the
episode where she first teams up with
Spike and jet she just she never leaves
but she also doesn't get along with them
she's rarely helpful and she mooches off
them in a very self-entitled way she's
not even subtle about it now I mean it
works for the character and I'm not
saying you like good I don't believe
that no I do but I just find myself
wondering why did he keep putting up
with her why is she still here and it's
not a problem unique to this show let me
be clear I often find myself wondering
the same thing about Rigel whenever I
rewatched Farscape but once I kind of
I'm not gonna say got over it I'm not
sure I ever did what I swallowed that I
found that her resistance to making
connections to be pretty relatable the
main episode where they give her detail
on her history to explain why she is the
way she is is fittingly titled my funny
Valentine and is actually not one that
I'm a huge fan of as I don't really
think it tells us much about her
relationships with people that we
couldn't have already guessed on our own
however she's also the focus of another
episode later on called speak like a
child too and despite actually being
absent for most of it that one that
works really well I don't want to spoil
the specifics but let me just say that
the disconnect between what Fey is now
and what she was at a forgotten more
innocent time in her life that basically
hits her like a freight truck and it's
devastating and
very real way that was basically the
point at which I felt like I properly
got her
and then there's jet now at first jet a
bit like Faye seems like a stock
character Faye was the self serving
femme fatale that nobody in their right
mind would ever trust jet was the tough
Papa Bear with the heart of gold which
she doesn't really know how to hide but
jet has what is to me not only the
single best episode that focuses on a
character's personal history but also
one of the best episodes of the show
period that one's called ganymede elegy
and it has jet finding his old
girlfriend and we learn about the
reasons for their breakup actually not
only do we as the audience learn it but
jet does too because she left him and he
never really understood why the reasons
that she gives and what we find out and
the way it reframes jet as a character
is just beautifully handled it's not a
big twist or some dark secret or a
reveal of some horrible thing that he
did it's just an aspect of his character
that we already knew about presented
from a new perspective and it changes
how you see him without feeling like a
rug pole or a retcon or not playing fair
it's really masterfully done so stepping
away from the characters what else is
there that works well but one thing it
looks really good despite the cowboy
title it's often got much more of a noir
light sort of fields of the stories it's
fun characters but a harsh world this is
made explicit in the very first episode
which I am going to spoil but come on
it's the first episode so in this one
spike makes a connection with a woman
wrapped up with the wrong guy and she's
just trying to get out of her lousy life
by the end of the episode she dies for
her trouble to some
mournful jazz she doesn't deserve it but
it doesn't matter the first episode is
actually also one of the stronger ones
for the record the very next episode
almost serves as a second part of the
show's thesis statement as it's a fluffy
little yarn about a runaway dog that's
played largely for laughs and between
the two you pretty much get the polar
extremes of what the show has a tendency
to be so that tonal whiplash from
episode to episode is a bit much for you
let me just warn you it's going to keep
happening for my part the best episodes
are the ones that lean more in the
direction of the serious or the
melancholy but before you take that as
an absolute most of the worst episodes
also fall into those kinds of categories
by and large the lighter ones kind of
just fall in the middle for me there are
a few standout funny ones usually the
ones that primarily focus on Edie
because Edie's just she's she's such a
goofy character you can build
ridiculousness around her without having
it undercutting the things that tends to
happen when the other three are
essential to a sillier kind of story so
one of the things that works in the more
melancholy episodes is a storytelling
approach that I think of in might head
in my head as small stories in a big
world it's where a large fantastical
world has been created but the
characters we watch and the stories that
we see are ultimately small and
unimportant within that world it's the
opposite of the sweeping epic where we
watch the actions of characters who will
define or reshape the world that they
live in
now the exemplar of this big world small
story storytelling for me at least is
the first Blade Runner film it is an
expanding lis expansive world and the
characters are small they no matter and
they know that that is a vibe that
is in this show as a whole and it's
prevalent in my favorite episodes very
prominently the world that the show
created clearly has bigger things going
on there's corporations there's you know
the way the government works or doesn't
work there's the degree to which the
crime syndicates are in control of
everything but the show and the
characters they really only ever just
kind of brush up against the edges of
the major players because they're not
really part of those stories and I like
that when it comes to the serious minded
or melancholy episodes that work a big
part of what helps elevate the whole
thing is the music I mean oh heck the
music even bolsters the episodes that I
don't like very much at least a little
bit the score is one thing that is
actually pretty much impossible to
overpraise about this show I will call
other things overrated not the
soundtrack the music for the show came
from composer and musician yoko kanno
she was attached early to the production
and it is rumored that some of EDS
eccentric mannerisms were actually
inspired by her jazzy would be the
easiest word to use to describe the
soundtrack but if I'm gonna say that I
need to clarify that I mean in the
broadest possible sense the music can be
all over the place from episode to
episode
somber bluesy piano dour saxophone lazy
harmonica raucous horns it's all jazz or
blues but it runs the gamut of the genre
honestly I could probably devote an
entire video to talking about just the
music you know if I was more versed in
how to dissect compositions or anything
like that instead I'm just going to give
you a few little tastes every episode
kicks off with this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a recurring tune to reflect the fact
that the crew barely scraped by goes
like this
[Music]
Edie chasing down a guy for the back of
magic mushrooms gets this as a score
[Music]
things can be bouncy they can be sad and
it always always fits perfectly maybe
the best way to illustrate what about
this show works for me is to focus on
some of my favorite episodes there's
really no way for me to detail this
section without spoiling some of these
episodes and their endings so be warned
if you haven't watched the show before
this might be the point in the video to
break off and just go do that if you
think you want to like I said the it's
hard to ruin the show as a whole but I
am gonna kind of spoil these episodes so
then the episode waltz for Venus spike
in avert Li picks up a groupie when a
young man sees him take down a
bountyhead on a transport the young man
wants spike to show him some of his cool
moves and he I mean basically
pesters the bounty hunter and shall
spike relents and tries to impart just a
few basics into the kid as the episode
moves on it turns out that the young man
is mixed up with the local crime
syndicate and he stole a rare and
valuable plant hoping that it's
medicinal uses could cure his sister's
blindness there's a climactic fight at
the end of the episode in which the
young man uses one of spikes moves to
dodge a thug
spike sees him do this gives him a sign
of approval it's a fun little moment of
triumph that's immediately cut short
when the young man is shot and killed
the episode concludes with the sister
regaining her sight
but it's not a joyful occasion because
her blindness didn't even bother her all
that much and she never asked her
brother to risk himself like that it's
this kind of melancholy and sadness
brought on by a universe that just
doesn't really care about you that is
the note that the show hits the best I
feel most of my favorite episodes such
as I already mentioned Ganymede elegy
some
for the devil and Bohemian Rhapsody go
for this kind of mood to one degree or
another with their endings if not
throughout the entire episode and this
feels about as good a point is Eddie to
talk about what I consider to be the
single best episode of the show and it's
the one I alluded to when I said that
there's an episode that genuinely
disturbs me because I'm going to talk
about Pierrot Lefou this one is truly
unique in the rum because it is flat-out
freaky the show only went for scary one
other time that was in these somewhat
underrated Toys in the Attic but it also
deliberately undercut that tone by the
ending here the show goes all-in I will
not lie everything about this show this
episode it just freaks me out from the
atonal music provided by Cano to the
overwhelming sense of dread and just
about everything going on with character
of mad Pierrot
his mannerisms tell so much of his story
which is made all the more terrifying
has his origins are laid bare it's the
rare thing that becomes scarier the more
you know about it and the episode
concludes in a way that just it shakes
me in the worst way which is to say the
best way so Pierrot is basically an
unstoppable killing machine with the
mind of a child this is the kind of core
concept that could be very cheesy but
it's played here for just the right kind
of disturbing the Glee with which
Pierrot kills and fights brings to mind
a preteen playing a video game with all
the cheats on he's enjoying what he does
but there's an ever-present sense that
he doesn't properly understand the
consequences of what it is that he's
doing it's fun and to him that's all
that matters but it's not just like some
kind of gleeful madness he is deeply
broken he's
when things don't go the way he wants
panicky at the sight of a cat the reason
for which gets a chilling reveal later
on and he only wants to play if he gets
to win at the end of the episode his
death is brought about when healers
spike to an abandoned amusement park
after getting thrashed around for a
while and with very little fight left in
him spike is finally able to throw a
knife at puro and cut his leg it's just
a scratch
really but just like a child hurt while
playing Pierrot breaks down he falls to
the ground crying for his mother because
it hurts he's bleeding and he doesn't
want to play anymore while he is in the
midst of his tantrum a parade of giant
animatronic characters which we've seen
coming for a bit of time now walks up
and crushes him he was fully capable of
getting out of the way
but he didn't because he was hurt and he
needed somebody to come and help him not
physically help him emotionally help him
he was too distraught to do anything
other than lay in the path of this thing
that would kill him the essence of a
troubled child captured so perfectly in
this character is what makes this death
so massively disturbing for me to watch
or honestly even recall in order to
write up the script for this thing
Pierrot is a very dangerous man
admittedly he is nothing short of a
monster but his monstrousness is so
childish that I cannot help but feel a
deep sense of injustice at his demise
he's to believably immature for me to
find this to be anything other than
unsettling and I kind of love it
unfortunately after a pure Olaf ooh it's
pretty much all downhill I didn't bring
up that yo-yoing of tone idly because it
really does persist throughout the
entire run of the show I can't help but
feel that I'd probably be better
disposed towards the show if it had
started out with a wider range of tones
but then like just narrowed it down and
focused more as it got to the tail end
of the run
but after pure Olaf ooh are some of the
most disposable and forgettable episodes
in the entire show it also doesn't help
that the show forces focus back onto
Spike and it hops too close with him
which means that now we're really
getting to the elephant in the room for
why I cannot get behind this show to the
degree that so many others seem to I've
been kind of dancing around the details
of spikes backstory episodes though I
have alluded to the fact that I don't
really like the backstory episodes in
general that said there are some good
ones Jed gets a great one with Ganymede
elegy but he also gets the painfully
predictable and trite black dogs black
dog serenade Fey has speak like a child
but before that we have to slog through
my funny Valentine and Spike Spike's
backstory episodes are just the worst
there are a few reasons for this firstly
as I've said spike is not nearly as cool
as he or the fans or the show seemed to
believe that he is so digging into his
self-serious fatalistic backstory just
comes across as astonishingly
pretentious secondly his crime syndicate
backstory is straight out of the big
book of new are cliches there's never a
curveball like the show was able to do
at least once for both fans yet but more
than anything it's because every time
the show gets into spikes backstory we
get treated to this guy
this is vicious yeah you heard me right
you thought jet-black was gonna be the
dumbest name that you were gonna hear in
relation to this show
I hate vicious I hate him he's stupid
he's cliche but what's worse he's a
cliche who feels like he stepped out of
a completely different show I mean look
at him look at this sephiroth knock off
with his freakin black shoulder burden
his black coat and his silver hair and
his big-ass sword and his pseudo poetic
monologuing he's every generic villain
from every anime ever seriously you can
plug him out of this drop him into
almost any other action anime that has
ever been made
he'd probably fit in better there than
he does here heck
he'd make more sense turning up in
Kingdom Hearts than he does in this show
I hey he's the one and only recurring
villain of the entire thing he's in five
episodes and he never gets any less dumb
his first appearance in Ballad of fallen
angels is probably the low point of the
entire show for me for a show that at
its best knows exactly how to play a
scene for the perfect result how to
balance all the elements it is so
infuriating for me that this episode
doesn't have the first clue how damn
generic pretentious and Hollow it is as
spike walks into a church to face
vicious to the sound of an organ and
these lyrics
[Music]
oh dear God if it had been wrapped up
anywhere besides the finale I wouldn't
be this annoyed I still would like this
character of these stories because they
suck but at least the show wouldn't have
decided that that was the taste it was
gonna leave in my mouth right when the
entire thing was over
ai ai ai ai just oh I can't with this
guy he he sucks I suppose I'll touch on
the movie briefly which was made after
the show ended but in terms of narrative
chronology is set between the episodes
of cowboy bunk bunk cowboy funk and
brain scratch towards the end of the
show's run and when it comes to the
movie I am NOT a huge fan the basic
approach was a solid enough idea
focusing on the biggest bounty the crew
ever chased down but the villain while
not as bad as vicious is very much cut
from the same cloth as that tool there's
a scene involving the villain and Fay
where she is made into this sexy damsel
in distress was which actually watching
that scene made me realize that despite
dressing the way that she does Fay is
not as sexualized in the show itself as
one would have expected so naturally the
action scenes are bigger but not in a
way that justifies them being as long as
they are there's like for example
there's an extended chase at the tail
end that kind of exemplifies this issue
if you're going to have an action scene
that goes on for more than a minute the
situation needs to evolve in some way as
it goes or you risk it just becoming
repetitive and boring by the time it's
over and this chase never evolves
it's just spike escaping from the
authorities and it takes them a while to
do it it's interspersed with other
scenes and every time the movie cut back
to the chase and just found myself
wandering
it's so going on also remember how I
mentioned that one of the things I
really like about the show is how the
characters aren't ever really directly
embroiled in truly world-shaking events
yeah well they are here because the
literal world is at stake and we get way
too much time spent with the corporation
and government officers involved in the
whole thing honestly it feels more like
ghost in the shell' stand alone complex
at times I'm not going to say it was
taking cues from that because that show
didn't actually start airing until 2002
and the film would have been well into
production by that but look it felt like
the completely wrong vibe there was
intruding in on the world of Cowboy
Bebop I don't want to give you the
impression that the film actively
doesn't work but for me it loses some of
the things that I personally really
liked about the show while playing up
some of the things that I don't like as
much or I feel just don't fit very well
but you know your mileage may vary
depending on what it is you like about
the show in the first place so that it's
cowboy bebop when it's good it's really
truly great it's best episodes are some
of the best examples of anime I have
seen it when it flies high it completely
soars but that's not all the time or
even consistently of the 26 episodes of
the show I would label 9 of them as
legitimately great 7 as varying flavors
of bad or forgettable and 10 that are
either just decent or too uneven to fall
firmly into the other two camps if you
like anime or if any of this sounded
like it might be up your alley
well it's probably worth giving it a try
for yourself if you haven't already
since the episodes are only
about a half-hour long I mean can I
actually binge through the whole thing
and the movie - in about a weekend if
you're serious about it and clear some
space but personally I still stand by
labeling the overall thing as overrated
not because it's bad but because it's
not the end-all be-all of anime shows
that way too many people I know seem to
pitch it as it's a good show that's
relatively accessible to audiences not
overly familiar with anime since it's
not dealing with very many of the more
specifically anime or Japanese tropes
like giant robots Japanese mythology
ninjas etc but it's not the pinnacle of
the art it's a little too loose it's a
little too undisciplined maybe it's just
a little too much like the jazz music it
relies so heavily on and maybe that was
even the point
but being uneven on purpose doesn't make
the viewing experience any stronger not
for me at least
so that's Cowboy Bebop and my thoughts
on it have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch so stuff
to do buttons links patreon merch P o
box social media it's all down below
click on the links check out the places
where they take you or don't if you
don't want to that's ok cuz at the end
of the day you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]